you're in the comedy clubs all the time
yeah and you're kind of a skeevy guy
that way but I'm always at 7-eleven but
I'm drugged yeah I go to the comedy club
Allison Janney got that going there's a
political correctness in comedy now have
you noticed a change what now that
you're in the clubs are people a little
more careful about their routines people
you know talk a lot about what you can't
say I think it's weird some of the
things we still can say like for example
it's 2018 we're very aware we're woke
you know our sinful we're hyper hyper
sensitive everything it's weird the
whitest man just said woke you're right
- laughs yeah well woke but yet there's
still some blind spots we have
culturally like it's completely fine to
be racist towards Italians in what way I
don't know if you've noticed some of you
are like oh oh this is about to get
weird I don't mean real races I might
mean like casual culturally acceptable
like I know some of you are Italian I'm
not Italian yet I have no fear being
like you want to go get a big bag this
is not a scandal it's true no one will
tweet about this no one cared oh okay
yeah in our video game yes yes
Coenen it's on me
Mario yes that's an impression one has
an immigrant struggling with the
language yeah it's absolutely right i'ma
Luigi I'm gonna win and I'm gonna get
the linguini don't make fun of them help
him out he's new I know but that is the
you're absolutely right no a mindset and
I'm gonna do I'm gonna add one oh and I
see if you agree the Irish of Cornell
one I've been around the most sensitive
people in the world and they're trying
to say sensitive things about all
different cultures and then whatever if
my ethnicity comes up they're like
you're all drunk everybody even Irish
people are like it's true ya know we can
do the voice no one gets mad yes we will
all be upset everyone yeah if you and I
did a show where I was an Irish guy and
you were yeah and we yelled each other
complaint would come in right cuz no one
writes letters anymore
they'd be really pissed on the Internet
that's the important thing
you